everyone loves a surprise cameo they
make every movie that much more fun
but there are some cameos so well hidden
because they're a special favor to a
star or director or some kind of
elaborate insight joke now they're easy
to miss here are sometimes our big stars
showed up in secret uncredited roles and
hardly anyone noticed Glenn Close hook
during one unforgettable scene in Steven
Spielberg's Peter Pan ref Captain Hook
brutally throws one of his own pirates
Cutlass into the boo box with a scorpion
it's enough to make any self-respecting
pirate scream like a girl
but in this pirates case he actually was
one that's actress Glenn Close under the
bushy beard decades before she earned an
Oscar nomination for playing another
male character in Albert Nobbs Peter
Jackson hot furs at the beginning of
this movie simon Pegg's cop character
gets stabbed in the hand by an unhinged
to Santa Claus
Santa's face is obscured by a beard but
that psychotic father Christmas is Lord
of the Rings director Peter Jackson who
was friendly with hoppers director Edgar
Wright
after Jackson invited right to visit the
set of King Kong white returned the
favor by extending an invite to the sets
of his film where Jackson volunteered to
do a cameo this scene was shot after
Jackson had lost a great deal of weight
and shaved his beard which means the
director were a phony fat suit for his
big moment on-screen Cate Blanchett hot
furs Peter Jackson wasn't the only big
Hollywood name to pop up in this British
cop comedy in another scene Simon Pegg
scarred sir meets up with his
ex-girlfriend that investigates her
named Jeanine who's played by Cate
Blanchett Blanchett was a big fan of
Edgar Wright zombie comedy Shaun of the
Dead and when she met him at a party he
offered her a cameo only one in which
her face would be totally obscured just
because he thought it would be funny to
cast an Oscar winner in a role which
should be completely unrecognizable
Danny Glover maverick in this 1994
big-screen remake of a classic TV comic
Western maverick is in a bank when a
robbery goes down leading the crooks as
a guy who uses a red bandana to cover up
his face he wouldn't want to be noticed
after all the scarf also did a pretty
good job of concealing the identity of
the actor playing the Bandit Mel
Gibson's Lethal Weapon co-star Danny
Glover Steven Spielberg the blue
whose brothers this film featured a
marvelous roster of legendary blues and
R&B musicians including Ray Charles
Aretha Franklin James Brown Cab Calloway
and John Lee Hooker but also making an
appearance as director Steven Spielberg
who struck up a friendship with Dan
Aykroyd and John Belushi a year earlier
and appears here as a clerk in a County
Assessor's Office dan Aykroyd Indiana
Jones and the Temple of Doom after
Steven Spielberg cameoed in dan Aykroyd
movie Aykroyd returned the favor at the
very beginning of the second Indiana
Jones Adventure a mustachioed British
man helps arrange transportation for
India 10 airports with one minor caveat
of course not even a silly accent can
entirely masca Croy's distinctive voice
which makes this cameo one that's easier
to spot than the rest
Bill Murray Dumb and Dumber to this
sequel to the classic idiot flick Dumb
and Dumber was written and directed by
Bobby and Peter Farrelly who also
directed Bill Murray in their 1996
bowling comedy kingpin like hot fudge
director Edgar Wright the Farrelly
Brothers thought it would be amusing to
cast a very well-known actor in the role
of ice pick Harry's meth making
roommates whose identity is completely
concealed with a breathing apparatus
throughout this one scene and Murray was
happy to trade his kingpin comb-over for
a hazmat suit Jimmy Buffett Jurassic
world when order inevitably breaks down
in the dinosaurs at Jurassic world
escape to terrorize the theme park
guests there's a few seconds of comic
relief an old dude in an orange shirt
runs away from the chaos and carnage
while carefully carrying two margaritas
who played this hero the planets most
ardent margarita lover of course
Margaritaville singer Jimmy Buffett
Stephen Colbert the hobbit the
desolation of smaug Stephen Colbert is a
huge j.r.r tolkien fan and scholar
having shown off his geek credentials
multiple times from The Colbert Report
and The Late Show and I smoked you like
a ham in 2013 he was rewarded for his
devotion with a small part in the second
installment of Peter Jackson's The
Hobbit trilogy Colbert appears on screen
for just a few seconds as one of
Laketown spies
in Wilson Rushmore Wilson co-wrote this
indie dramedy cult classic with
childhood friend and frequent
collaborator was under son and his two
active brothers show up in minor roles
and replace a coach at the titular
school and Luke plays a doctor who goes
on a date with rosemary played by Olivia
Williams with whom most of the men in
the movie are totally obsessed these are
or scrubs oh are they but Owen is in the
film too if you look closely he plays
Edward Appleby Rosemary's - ceased
husband who appears exclusively in a
couple pictures on the wall in
Rosemary's house basically everyone in
star wars the force awakens when the new
installments of this beloved franchise
hits theaters in 2015 it was full of
secret cameos from actors who just
wanted to be part of the fun so when
raid trades salvaged parts - his jacket
junk dealer in exchange for Russians
there's actually a familiar face under
all that latex padding and CGI actor
writer and total Star Wars superfan
Simon Pegg and he's not the only one
remember the storm trooper who released
this ray in this pivotal scene your
weapon that's James Bond himself Daniel
Craig trading as dinner jacket for a
suit of white plastic armor and the
final surprise throughout the movie
you're hearing but not seeing a famous
comedian the little chirps and blips
made by bb-8 the world's most adorable
droid are actually the vocalizations of
actor and Saturday Night Live alumnus
Bill Hader thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you're love tea
[Music]